[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link
and I'm Rhett this week at the round
table of dim lighting we're going to be
hearing uh about links spring break trip
to the snow-capped mountains Rocky
Mountains I went on the most ambitious
private ski trip that uh Chrissy and I
were in charge of
uh that ever ever
it was very ambitious and let me tell
you I need to share
a story
of embarrassment oh you've got a story
of embarrassment and humiliation well
that's a change of pace and yeah it
involves me being the one embarrassed oh
and humiliated and also the source of
the embarrassment yeah the source and
the recipient I don't there's no part of
the story that I'm proud of
I feel like I have to share the story
to redeem some sort of value out of it
well like give me some YouTube either
laugh at me that's my Mantra at this
point when something starts going south
I'm like I've got a podcast yeah I know
it's great to have a podcast
so you can either laugh or you can
Ultra cringe yeah like in fact I I use
it as a coping mechanism now
when I get in a situation where I can
get scared
scared where I'm like I might die or
like oh yeah this could go south so fast
and then I'm like but you know what if I
get through this I'll have a story to
tell it's really I don't want to be like
I might die but hey I have a podcast no
it's like no I'm saying it's a good like
coping mechanism it calms you down I
don't use it when I'm about to die into
Justified I do it when when I've done
something really dumb
really embarrassing
and I'm like well
at least I can share it
and we can get a good laugh out of it
hopefully oh I won't laugh at you
do you promise to laugh
so I want to share this story because I
just feel like it's the only way to
redeem what I did and then I want to
forget it happened entirely okay then
once this immortalized on the internet
all right so I'm going to tell you that
story and I will contextualize my
ambitious vacation ski trip as part of
that
so stay tuned but I know in my absence
did you not make a a link
free podcast
uh yeah I did and did that come out last
week and did I listen to it no because
I'm not in it yeah I don't listen to the
ones I'm in I don't feel any obligation
to listen but like is there anything I
need to know about it that everybody
else knows
uh do I need to listen to it
probably not I mean well hold on so you
you you you make it about me uh uh I
mean you were mentioned I mean I think
we got a couple good shots of your empty
chair
um
there were some questions there were
some questions about you that I answered
uh but I do you think you need to listen
to it yeah is there something I should
know busy for that uh no okay it's not
while the cat's away no you know me mice
will play you know me well enough to not
need to listen to me talk without you
there you know what I mean unless you're
dropping some
some some
non-truths about me when people ask some
questions that I didn't end up answering
because I like what's the one thing
that you've never told us about link or
something like that I'm like I can't
I spent some time thinking about those
things and I just didn't there's nothing
there's nothing there's nothing there's
nothing
um I better not be anything you know uh
it but it was horrible it was horrible
without you here I'm sure no one left
and I had I struggled through the whole
thing I struggled keeping the
conversation going it was really short
because I ran out of stuff to talk about
you know okay good good good good thank
you thank you but and I'm gonna give you
the the return favor I haven't heard
about that I'm gonna do one without you
because you're going on a vacation I've
got my own trip our kids Spring Breaks
no longer line up and now that we've got
two kids in college and kids at home
it's just
the months of the months of March and
April at this point
I always barely see each other
no we see each other plenty
it's good
yeah but we used to sync up our all our
uh spring break vacations right and
everyone just complicated things in
mythical hereby not doing that are you
making it do you make any mythical
decisions that
um I should have known about uh actually
brought me uh it was actually remarkably
efficient
hahaha
but did you decide anything that you
knew I would have done the opposite oh
yeah when you were running the company I
definitely took advantage of that like
opportunity no uh no it didn't do that
nothing I didn't do that but I did do
something
um
that I could I would like to tell you
about yeah that you do know that but you
don't know the details
so I took this opportunity while you
were gone
to uh join you as a
Open Water certified scuba diver
surprise congratulations hello guys can
scuba dive I knew that you were you were
getting your certification which
required you went to Catalina too right
yeah yeah same process two-day company
same process you had to stay overnight
Shepard out on the island with Shepard
in order to uh do everything you needed
to do in the open water in the actual
ocean yeah this is where my mind's at
right now I'll tell you a little bit
about the how it went but the main thing
that I was thinking was
why did you not
upon
having this happen to you
immediately come to me grab me put both
hands on me on my shoulders look me
directly in the eye and say
you have to get scuba certified ASAP
it's the best thing ever
you totally undersold it man you
undersold it
I'm just gonna be honest with you here I
didn't I didn't literally grab you you
should have forced me
I had to wait a whole year before I get
to do this
well you the adventures that we can go
on now dude I talked about it on the
show you did talk talk about it we
talked about it in our normal lives you
talked about how good of a time you had
but you did not insist like if I had it
done at first I would have got home I
would have gone over to your house I
would have been like listen you need to
set the date right now you got to get
this you got to do this pick a son
who's willing to go with you and do it I
did tell you to do it I said
you would really enjoy this and you know
what you said you know well I'm a beard
you know I can't I can't do the mask
thing because my beard uh I got this
mustache and you know I'm not going to
shave my mustache yeah this was whenever
I bring it up that's what you would talk
about yeah but you're not broken through
that I'm just being honest with you you
should have forced this is your problem
you should have forced your way through
that I'm not gonna I'm not gonna beg you
to do something that well I would have
begged you
just gonna say that I told you to do it
I didn't ask you to do it you suggested
it like hey man I was like there's a
good restaurant there's a good
restaurant on the other side I built it
up maybe you should go what what road
are you living in now you should have
picked me up and driven me there
yeah that you know next time and you
know what the brutal honesty is right
that's not it's not my job
to make you happy well I did everything
I could I shared my experience yeah and
you know what
I I I had I had I had worthy companions
I have my son Lincoln and I had Chase I
replaced you with Chase and I was also I
got to talk to Chase he he has undersold
it too
now for those of you out there who but
you're welcome to join us now who do
have a beard let me just go ahead and
say that that whole thing about the
beard being a problem
that's oversold that is so so oversold
you get the right mask and you're
talking about mustache here really no
beer and you shave a you know first of
all I think I could get away with it
without doing this but as you can see
it's growing back in but just a little
like literally like 10 hairs at the top
of your mustache just enough to get the
mask under there great little nose
I don't know listen man I felt like uh
uh about you know I wasn't I didn't keep
anything from well I think this is the
thing is that you uh you talked about
how you've always been scared of being
underwater right like so you've had a
lifelong fear of like holding your
breath underwater and being underwater
so you had to so your story was a lot
about like overcoming fear yeah and the
thing that I did not realize is I've
always loved being underwater and like
diving and holding my breath and going
as deep as I can and
I just assumed like yeah this beard
thing I don't want to get like I you you
didn't tell me okay this is another
thing I'm gonna blame on you you did not
tell me that if you're 60 feet
underwater it doesn't matter how deep
you are
it makes sense but I didn't know that if
your mass fills up with water you just
literally breathe out of your nose and
fill it back up with air I did tell you
that
you didn't make it clear man I just feel
like it wasn't clear I feel like those
words I feel like there should have been
a chart I feel like you should have set
me down whiteboard
I I just feel like it could have been
more forceful you needed to discover
this on your own terms in your own time
and I'm glad that you did because I'm
gonna benefit from this already he's
been talking about
we need to go down here and do it yes
you go up here and do it we need to
start traveling places to like the best
scuba yes because you loved it so much
and I'm like this is what I want someone
to do all the thinking for me because I
don't know I don't remember I've
forgotten everything about it I need to
be recertified uh and you're gonna do
that for me you got it so um
yes Adam Chase I'm sorry buddy I'm not
gonna get out well no first of all Jason
can go with it nope he's out I can't
have I can't have that many traveling
companions the thing that uh was
um
you you can imagine this
but of course when you're diving in uh
California you're in in a Catalina
you're diving in like the kelp forest
and so this this feeling I've always
always wanted to fly but it's the
closest thing to flying too right I'm
sure I told you that I'm sure I
described it you probably did you
probably did you probably did
um anyway I'm not going to tell you
extensively about this we're gonna hear
it from link and because I'm going to uh
my spring break I'm going to uh uh the
Caribbean and I'm going to dive in a
shipwreck and I'm going to dive on a
like a wall
so okay I'll I'll talk talk more about
that maybe get some good video I'm
talking to chase right now this is the
thing this is also why I'm I'm good I'm
a good friend because you don't buy
anything but like when I get into things
I immediately am like well what do you
actually need to do this and make it
cool so I'm like I'm talking to chase
about his 360 camera so that when I come
back and I talk to talk about my
vacation there'll be footage of me in a
shipwreck
but you talk about things which only we
can just imagine yeah because I did it
for me uh well I'm doing it for you
listening
I'm doing no I'm doing it for me but I'm
like you're doing it for the write-off
uh well Chase has this you're putting
this all in the company it has this
camera that you just like literally
float next to you and it just films your
whole thing in 360. you don't even have
to think of it I know that he he brought
that when we went out to the Channel
Islands and he lost it yeah he did but
he did he felt it again no someone found
it like floating out and then they
returned the ocean and called them
um so anyway I'm on board I absolutely
love it like it was just wonderful and I
am yes it's wonderful and uh and I
definitely think we got it Shepard loved
it I'm sure Shepherd was all in like
both of us y'all didn't have any anxiety
overcome no we loved it we loved it
that's cool man so
um cold is balls out there but and it
was called the surface temperature was
57 degrees well water temperature why is
it cold as balls my balls aren't really
ever that cold well they're colder than
the rest of your body that's why they're
in the ball sack oh
and the colder they get the more sperm
you make but we don't need sperm anymore
no we don't but we make
we still just understand we still make
semen
a lot of people seem to be confused
about that
well this is the tangent
so this is that was going to be my wreck
you just stole my thunder
um the other thing that you undersold
I'm sorry I'm on this uh you undersold
Catalina Island man like you like you
you actually talked exclusively
negatively about it I I don't recall yep
you didn't say that on the on the thing
but you were like it's I mean I was like
because you know I'm also I'm obsessed
with Islands I've always had this weird
thing about Islands I love ice I mean
there's a putt-putt course see exactly
you're still in this negativity spiral
I mean there's an ocean around it and
there's an amazing kelp for us but the
island itself I I told you I wouldn't
spend more than two nights there yeah
right yeah yeah I stand by that well
when we arrived
the sunrise was shining on you know the
town of Avalon and it was I was like
this is this place is enchanting that's
that's the exact words that I used when
I told Shepard about it
and yeah there's not a whole lot going
on there it's I'm not going to spend a
week there or anything there's more ice
cream parlors than people uh
but also finding out about like did you
did you find out about the giant
squirrels and the dwarf foxes did you
find out about this did you see this no
so one of the one of the reasons I love
islands is because of the you know the
isolation of the island not only does it
make weird stuff start happening in
terms of the people but it makes very
weird stuff start happening in terms of
the Flora and the fauna
because of their their isolated
populations and evolution begins taking
hold like well like it does everywhere
but there's a giant squirrel so a lot of
times when a population of a particular
animal uh is isolated on an island
depending on what who his competitors
are it will either get smaller or bigger
and so just look at Madagascar the
squirrels are like 25 percent bigger
than a normal squirrel and I didn't see
one but I saw it like the museum that we
visited there's a museum you went in
well actually there I think the squirrel
is at like a sporting goods store but uh
it's a big ass squirrel and they have a
little tiny Fox and they also have a
butterfly that's only on the island and
then they have trees that are only on
the island the only place in the world
and then there's
30 there's a 39 mile trans Catalina
trail that you can hike from one end of
the island to the other and there's
bison on the island because the Bison
herd was isolated during a John they
used it for a John Wayne movie and then
they just left them on the island and
now there's just this like roaming herd
of bison that they have to call it not
by killing them but just by herding them
up and then they give them to like bison
Farms where they're like trying to
repopulate bison in America or something
like that every like so and so number of
years they have to do this huh and the
whole island is owned by the Wrigley
family you know Wrigley spearm spearmint
gum in that big house that you see on
the upper left when you get there that
big mansion that's the Wrigley Mansion
and apparently like the grandkids of the
Wrigleys run the island and make all the
decisions about thing there's like a
council
and you know they also you know they're
from Chicago right so Wrigley Field so
the Chicago Cubs had their spring
training on Catalina Island from 1921 to
1951. this is all fascinating I was just
like what this is crazy and it's just
quaint it's beautiful and the fact that
the Dive Center is right there and it's
just steps down into a kelp forest and
then you go
and I heard the underwater school I
heard that you
took your you rented your tanks in LA
and took them to the island yeah that
wasn't my decision though well your doc
whoever took you on the your thing was
like you you should have told them
no bueno because it was Heavy they're so
heavy the tanks are so heavy yeah that's
the only thing I'm worried about you
can't rent them on the island we should
have done that not only can you rent
them so like
we had to get we had to get the tanks
refilled right yeah so we were because
we were using the the casino Point uh
Dive Center right there we would
get our tanks and our weights by the way
you can also enrich your weights like
you were carrying your weights so heavy
but you had like 60 extra pounds of
luggage which I can't believe that
because just the other stuff alone is
crazy amount of weight
uh you probably had a wheeled card
though I did yeah yeah they didn't give
us that because we didn't have this
other stuff but you just you dive and
then you go you take your tank and they
give you a new one and then you go back
into the water
it's so convenient it's wonderful it's
like I well I like to think that I
earned it it's like a Wonderland
it's like a Wonderland it's a Wonderland
and I just feel like you you said ah a
couple of days there you've seen
everything you need to see if I would
have told you everything you just told
me when you did it you'd have been
disappointed I gave you a gift okay well
it was unattentional
speaking of a gift look at this t-shirt
it's a it's a puff painted
GMM logo that's right there you go a
flower you're trying to make it sound
different but you ended up just saying
look at this am I doing the same thing I
did for Catalina just underselling it
yeah yeah make it seem like some people
want t-shirt is the GM logo but it's
it's um flowers and it's puff paint and
you if you look at it and you like it
you should buy it if you look at it and
you don't like it buy something else
because we got a lot of [__]
mythical.com
I have notes Jamie and Jenna loved it
and I'm not saying it's just for girls
right I'm not saying that yeah
I actually quite like it I'm also
wearing it because it's for me
I don't quite like it I like it too I
wish I had put some puff paint
if you look at it really closely it's
just like you're in a a wildflower
Forest yeah if somebody gets really
close to you it's like they're in a in a
meadow how's that for selling it back up
you're like wait wait is this a is this
a logo for an internet show
tell me about that
mythical.com
so we went to Park City it's the second
year in a row we took spring break but
this is a special spring break because
it's Lincoln's senior year
and you know I'd been perusing Airbnb
well in advance I like to find a good
spot and I was just thinking this is a
special year for him I'm willing to kind
of
blow it out a little bit and I found
this
like big house that was it was the only
one like this uh and it said rare find
on Airbnb well they're selling it yeah
they're selling it yeah you could have
said that about the shirt it was like a
big log cabin type thing on the ski
slopes it it had like a skiing ski out
and the big thing about skiing is like
getting everybody in the car and Chrissy
doesn't ski so then she's relegated to
just being
chauffeur for all of us to go skiing
drop us off coordinating to pick us up
trying to find parking I was like oh
this is this is a an amazing luxury here
this is a good find and then I was like
you know what we have a lot of room
Lincoln
bring your friends
I can accommodate up to four of your
friends good God so Lincoln and his four
friends me and Christy Lando Lily he's
got four friends that's cool he's at
home oh he's got a lot of friends
uh he had to narrow it down
it's more popular than both of us right
uh how did that work
to the to the top four sort of just
naturally presents yeah I think it it
simplified itself some people couldn't
come some people didn't want to ski some
people who had never skied or one person
who had never seen snow was did come
they come to the top of the list yeah
you want to have somebody around who's
like oh look at this let's watch him see
snow for the first time
um wow and then Lily was able to come
and her boyfriend okay so here we go
there's 10 of us well in this house I
mean and who's in charge and we've uh
Christy good we we flew
we like with coordinated flights for all
of us we had to get like we had to rent
two cars at the airport to get everybody
from the airport up to the house in Park
City yeah and then Lando's best friend
his parents happened to be staying in
Park City because they're spring land of
spring at the same time and so as his
friends so like they were there so there
was this other family of four that we
were meeting up with so like the first
night
the well the second night we were there
we had made reservations for 14. that's
a miracle that's a lot of people to
actually in Park City to find a a
restaurant between Christy and Kara they
were able to find this place and
um secure all 14 of us eating like at
this like nice steakhouse type place in
a yurt it was awesome but here was what
was so
much a feat about it we were sitting
down at one end of the table
me and Christy and Alex and Tara uh
those are the the adults from the other
group you know and uh because we're
friends with them we're having a good
time and at one point Alex says he's
like look down there the rest of the
table and you know the other I looked
around at all the kids like
you got Lily and her boyfriend you got
Lincoln all his friends and Lando and
his friend like they're all just talking
to each other having a blast
and that that was a that was a big early
moment that I like felt great about this
ambitious decision because I was really
nervous I mean the logistics involved in
getting that many people somewhere and
knowing that everybody's not gonna make
it back home in one piece someone's
gonna get hurt I mean when you're
bringing that many people when there's
14 people on a mountain well 13 because
Christy didn't ski I just didn't I was
like
I'm a proud of us for trying this but
it's it's gonna be riddled with defeats
because at some point the number of
people really starts to play into the
statistics of it all I know exactly so
having that early victory of just
looking at a table having this moment of
gratitude that you bringing this many
people together at one table and
everybody of all ages is having a great
time it's like all of a sudden I'm
getting a good feeling about this I'm
starting to feel
confident that this was awesome and you
know what that I'm an awesome dad okay
and there is when you went wrong I mean
not that you're not but I'm an awesome
dad for doing this you gotta Pride Gods
before the fall it made me feel good
when the parents of Lincoln's friends
before we went would say to us
are you sure you're gonna do this
yeah uh thank you for doing this
yeah I was like no this would be fun but
they'd like enhance my trepidation
um so we bought you know uh our
high school friend uh lifelong friend
Eric you know lives out there who hooked
us up with buddy passes getting that
many ski passes will set you back
so uh he he achieved a discount but that
meant we had to like buy all the passes
up front
um so like I was buying
snowboard lessons for Lincoln and his
friends because Lincoln's only skied
and they have they wanted to learn how
to snowboard right and then I'm buying
passes for like three days for everybody
else Lily even said she wanted to ski
get back on the skis I thought she was
done but I was like okay this is good
um so I had to buy all of the lift
tickets in in advance for all of the
days and of course after the first day
they're learning they're learning how to
snowboard and then there's certain
people who just like oh I don't know if
this is for me that's a man learning the
snowboard I don't care how old you are
it's really really tough you remember
when we learned a snowboard as teenagers
I think we were in college when we
learned to snowboard because we
sophomore year it was just it was a
group of like six or eight guys and we
went somewhere like we stayed in this
condo that probably had like one or two
beds and so we learned how to snowboard
no no classes we didn't even know no
instructions we didn't know you could do
that no instructions we definitely
wouldn't have paid for it and no no no
no we weren't paying for anything we did
buy our own snowboards we were like
committed to it in that way snowboard
snowboard boots
of course no helmets at the time and I
remember after falling on my hands and
my wrists and busting my ass and just
like because on a snowboard you either
fall forward and catch yourself or you
fall backward and catch yourself with
your butt and
um but you did do it and that night we
had to sleep on the floor of that condo
and I remember
being and when I woke up I just the pain
of everything is what woke me up and I
was so stiff
that's sophomore in college you know I
had a lot of I had some I wouldn't say
athletic prowess but I had some you know
I was young and surprised you were a 19
year old person I was 19. yeah
I couldn't get off the floor yeah like I
talking like a 88 year old man I
couldn't get off the floor 88. yeah
that's what I felt like that's exactly
what I felt like
the boys didn't have it that bad that I
was kind of disappointed they didn't go
hard they didn't go hard because they
had an instructor and they actually said
it was boring and useless do you know
what the the biggest difference actually
besides the instructor it was me not
being there location we learned on the
icy hard pack slopes of North Carolina
they learned on the
frou-frou fluffy slopes of and let me
tell you the Rocky Mountain there's so
much snow like coming out of the
driveway of the place we stayed which
had been you know they maintained it
throughout all the Snows it was clear
but then on either side we're talking
easily four and a half feet of snow on
either side of the driveway everywhere
on top like on top of the the roof and
it was just
when we arrived and we were like getting
like looking around the house all of a
sudden we heard something that sounded
like
a cataclysmic earthquake
and it was the snow falling off the roof
of the house
onto there was a hot tub there and it
fell on the hot tub which the cover was
on the hot tub but there was so much
snow that fell off it collapsed the
cover and it just filled the hot tub
with snow which is not conducive to
hotness of tub no but that kid that had
never seen snow before that's pretty
cool that was pretty cool for him that
kid that's his first that's his first
experience right
um so by day two I noticed when I was
going out with Lando skiing and the boys
were doing some more snowboarding so
you're you're skiing at this point I'm
skiing with Lando got it and his friend
and uh Alex and Tara
Lily elected not to go out the first day
I was like fine whatever I bought you
this lift ticket but we have an extra
day on the end so you can use your three
days starting tomorrow
and then I was like I gotta let go of
this people just gotta do it they gotta
do you have boyfriends he just he's yeah
he's uh he's uh he's out there okay
balls to the wall got it
um
and yeah it's occurring me some people
are they're going to discover that it's
not for them that happened day two
Christy's like I'm gonna make a run to
the grocery store two of Lincoln friends
are like oh we're gonna go with you and
do that you know you don't want to
snowboard when you're like I'm gonna go
with your mom to the grocery store
two two of the four dropped out on day
two yeah and so I'm like I'm not gonna
guilt them about this you know I don't
want to push them but now I got these
passes that I'm not using and I'm
thinking I should have pushed them well
I didn't buy
I can go I can go another day now and
then I'm like with I'll just use one
because it's like a credit card and with
the credit card then you know they just
scan it and you get on the lift and then
you're up there and like in it and it
has the number of days on it that you
bought so I'm like
the third day we went out
was when I was like today I'm going to
snowboard I haven't snowboarded in over
a decade I want to I want to ski with
Lincoln he's going out with the friends
that there's like
three other guys the non-grocery guys
yeah one of them went back and
snowboarded the third day real quick
just interject I'm not saying you should
have done this I'm just telling you what
I what I would have done because that
second day discouragement is such a real
thing
that night after day one you need while
you're all at dinner yeah you give a
speech you give a dad speech and you say
guys
um
tomorrow you're gonna wake up and you're
not you're very likely going to be a
little bit sore it's going to be like do
I have to get cold again do I have to
put all this gear yeah and you're gonna
be faced with resistance to doing this a
second day you're gonna be tempted to
grocery shop but here's the thing if you
get through the resistance of day two
and the resistance of day three you are
securing for yourself a potential
lifetime of enjoyment of this hobby but
you got to get through these first
couple of days and then they wake up and
they feel a little bit of Shame and then
they go and they do it again they don't
go to the grocery store yeah I I didn't
want to be that guy who was gonna that
didn't work well with my own family so I
didn't want to put it on like Lincoln's
friends because again I'm the superhero
Dad I'm the cool dad okay I'm anything
hey anything if you don't want to go you
don't have to go you know I'm the cool
dad
and plus I I started to calculate the
some of us who want to go for a
fifth day we weren't planning on
snowboarding on Friday or skiing and
then Lincoln was loving it
and after the day two he was like this
is I think this is my favorite thing
that I've done so snowboarding comparing
us to compare to skiing or just being
almost compared to anything but like
definitely snowboarding over skiing he
loved it so I was like I want to go out
with you the third day and now because
some people didn't go out yesterday I've
got let's see Michael has a pass that he
he has another credit so I'll just I can
use that and so it was me it was Lincoln
two of his friends and me on the
snowboard for the first time in over a
decade
and we snowboard out of the house I and
I I determined well my pass if Michael
wants to go out tomorrow I need to use
his pass today so that I can instead of
using it tomorrow because that way he
has the option to go out with his
passing I can use my pass tomorrow
here's the day so I took his
and I'm I'm kind of concerned about
am I gonna is it like riding a bike
snowboarding
um and you ski from the house you ski
down to this little lift that nobody
goes on
to like it's kind of in a weird spot to
really get you to the main space so we
like
we get we skied down snowboarded down to
that I was feeling okay
going up the I got on the lift
uh with Lincoln two other friends behind
us and I'm feeling I'm I'm feeling a
little trepidated here
you know I I did break my pelvis and
yeah receiving uh concussion I lost
eight hours of My Life as a result of
permanently but um but I gave it back to
you you did many times over many forms
and the and the rest of the viewing
audience but
um when we get up to the front of the
line
um I'm in I'm in front of the boys and
there's like somebody scanning everybody
uh you know 25 year old woman
scans me first
no it scanned okay and she said um
sir what's your name
uh
when someone asks you your name
and
it takes you
a long time to answer yeah I think that
throws up red flags because at that
moment when she was like sir what's your
name it occurred to me for the first
time that this might happen I was in no
way prepared I had no story I had
nothing I just didn't think I was like
they're gonna scan it I'm gonna go on
it's just it's it's a credit I paid for
it
and so when and then I'm thinking
I'm thinking a lot right now instead of
telling her what my name is right and
she's coming to conclusions about you
and so I'm like um
ugh Michael
his name was Michael
after all
the name on the card
because I could see her look at the
scanner it's like the scanner had a
thing on like a screen on it okay like I
was like Michael's name popped up I was
like Michael
and of course that had been a lot longer
than it needed to be for me to produce
my name okay hold on Michael one second
you're saying that you got these tickets
through our friend
but they he's not Michael
no it's Eric but everybody's ticket had
their name on it matter of fact they
wrote the name on it so everyone could
keep their right credit card in their
pocket and not get them mixed up
so why did you I don't understand where
the Michael comes from because it was
Michael's card and I knew that when
she's looking at the scanner that his
name popped you didn't you just kind of
mixed all the cards up it's like you
don't matter who gets what card no rat I
told you I picked Michael's card up to
use that day because he didn't use it
okay I wasn't using it that day got it
so she said sir what's your name
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick boom Michael
and then she says
um uh she's like
she's like well
uh you know she's and then I'm like what
what do I say what am I say now and then
she's like what's up Sir this is um
and then I I was like oh this
this must be my I must have got my son's
card instead of my card
is his name Michael and I I turned
around to the boys Lincoln and his
friends who were watching this all
happen and I turned to them and I was
like
guys
um I I got the wrong card I got I got
little Michael's card oh no no
no no
and uh little Michael Michael Jr oh no
and so then as I'm turning back around
from the boys you know I just thought
that would play it off hey boys you know
what you're gonna have to go up the
mountain without me I got little
Michael's card and as I'm turning back
that was pretty good though good
thinking little Michael
uh turning back to the woman she said um
sir what's your last name
and uh I did not know Michael's last
name
so what I heard myself say to the woman
was
going on here
hold on you said that I said that
and I was and so and then I heard myself
saying I'm like oh that's how you're
playing this you're you're escalating
this
and um hold on you took like an
aggressive posture I'd noticed that
what's happening you're such a strange
man and she's and I said
um she said sir can I see your ID I was
like I don't have it little Michael has
it and then she said
he's at the grocery store can I see your
phone
uh with some form of like your name
connected with anything on your phone
and I was like I'm not giving you my
phone you said that I said that
[Music]
ah something about the way that she I
felt like she was trapping me and I and
I got and I think I got angry but you
know what I think I was I was getting
kind of embarrassed
Maybe
a little bit
so I said I'm not giving you my phone
and um she said sir can you can you step
out of line with me
how many people are in line
um I don't know 75
maybe a hundred at this point it's
getting longer do you have a uh hat on I
have on a helmet good I have on goggles
great yeah yeah for real
you could be anybody you could be little
Michael we do it's hard to tell and
behind all that she said
sir
you're not 17 years old ah I knew it
and then you could well did you go keep
going with that actually I am uh
she that she said that as we were
walking out of the line as I was being
escorted
out through the ropes to the just to the
outside not we're not we're still where
everyone could see me you know this is
not a private location so you're not 17.
and I was like oh [__] not only is his
name associated with it his last name is
associated with it and his freaking age
is associated with it his birth date is
on here yeah
so she pulls me out of line the boys are
going on
this lift at this point oh they're going
on without you I told him to you know
yeah you don't stand here and watch this
I thought yeah I was like guys please
look away look away forget this as
quickly as possible and
um yeah I totally did Lincoln say
anything to you as he was they didn't
say anything I did not make eye contact
with my son or his friends but guys go
on little Michael's got to figure this
out on his own Super Dad was melting
into a puddle
on after being escorted to the side and
they call in reinforcements and another
fully suited employee shows up and I'm
like oh [__] what am I gonna do this is
aggressive as I was walking out of the
line it was like what's Happening Here
you said that yeah I was like what I was
like what is happening here hold on so
so you did it you escalated again yep
okay
well let me just tell you okay I it was
as if I was hearing myself say it and
then observing that this is what this is
the decisions that someone else was
making it was an out-of-body experience
they caught in reinforcements and then I
was like what am I gonna do am I gonna
am I gonna get
arrested well I've seen that I've seen
the videos am I gonna get am I gonna get
escorted off the mountain and are they
gonna call in the cops wait is this
illegal what I've done I mean I'm
impersonating a 17 year old who I know
not his last name
and so I was like oh crap I got to
change gears here so I took my goggles
off
put my goggles up and I said she had a
name tag on I'm not gonna call her by
her real name
Angie I said it's not around
honestly I don't remember her real name
because I want to forget her entirely
just like I hope she forgets me entirely
but something tells me that ain't gonna
happen yeah
because I said I put my goggles up you
know at this moment this is like I'm
getting real with you and I said Angie
my name's link I lied to you I lied to
you
and the other guy the other employee at
this point says
link from Red link
man I don't know if this is getting
worse what's up man why is that and I
gave him a fist bump and I'm thinking
hey this is all right this is I got this
i got this now it's both good and bad
both good and bad I understand like
please make this better and then I turn
to Angie and I'm like expecting like I'm
embarrassed but yeah it's it's me you
know that guy from the internet
the only thing she says with a blank
face is
um
sir I need to take your card or I need
to take Michael's card
and then she usually took it out of my
pocket and just handed it to her and I'm
like yeah you know I he's here he didn't
want to ski I just thought I could take
and then I'm going into the truth but it
was way too late for her I don't even
know she was still there as I was
explaining this to the fan employee
who I thought could be who would be like
hey man don't worry don't worry about it
yeah he Michael's not skiing today
you're using his and you'll use her
tomorrow they take this very seriously
this is like just so you understand this
is like one of the only things that
Angie cares about like the one of the
clearly her job
is to do what she's doing the reason
that she's there is to scan you in and
make sure that you are the person who
you are she's probably rewarded for
catching people who are trying to
impersonate it's like all of a sudden
you're expecting Angie to not do her job
I didn't steal the card was all I'm
saying I reallocated the purchase that I
had made to myself from someone who was
never going to use it which is what I
explained to the ticket counter when I
took the Walk of Shame
from the line because at that point I
was like
I'll figure this out I apologize and I
walked away honestly I walked away
because I didn't want to stay there and
get like arrested or something
[Laughter]
and so I took that walk of shame over to
the ticket booth and had like a
17-minute conversation with the guy
trying to get him to transfer the
Michael's Day to my card
no also print me a new card
okay which I I did succeed at that and
then I'm like communicating with the
boys they finally ski back down and I
get in line with them and uh
I count on the living I had to go buy
Angie to get all the lift and I was like
I was like looking the other way and
like
she's scanning me and I'm like oh God is
she gonna figure is she gonna recognize
me
and what if she didn't say anything she
was in a conversation while she was
booping
which if that would have happened the
first time I would have got through
of course then I would have come back
down and it would have happened again
and again and again I just didn't think
through any of this I'm innocent I tell
you it's evident I'm innocent yet I'm
guilty but I did it in a very innocent
way I'm like the most innocent guilty
person on the slopes today is what I'm
feeling okay and I'm not trying to put
this on Angie but
the way she did it
really hurt my feelings
I mean
she she's like
sir what's your name she's like trapping
me uh what's your last name like she
knew from the beginning that I was not
17. why didn't she say
uh sir the card you have is for a 17
year old so there's some problem here
and then yeah I could have lied I would
have still lied but there's some problem
at least shoot him and like
sir
the card I scanned is a 17 year old car
like she could have given me the benefit
of the doubt
I just I feel like I deserve this is an
interesting interesting I'm looking
around the room for support no one's no
one's helping me I'm glad I don't have a
microphone today
yeah I I elected not to give you a
microphone no I didn't but
uh
uh wow okay that's an interesting take
that uh Angie she humiliated me
well no I think you did that all on your
own Michael
um
the thing that okay so first of all
yeah and if I would have said I knew his
last name it wouldn't have helped
the initial Choice
um
to use somebody else's card because you
have an extra day okay we've all been
there we've all done something like this
right okay yeah now
you I think you do well some people know
that the information associated with the
person their name and their birthday is
going to show up on the scanner I should
have known that you know what because
I'm the one who provided all that
information when I bought the tickets
like I mean birth date last names
but the most interesting part of this
and we've we've we've talked about this
before
uh is your tendency to
escalate that's the most interesting
part of this thing because I was just
kind of I was embarrassed but there's
love there's a neat like it's not
calculated you're not like I'm gonna go
be an [__] there's a
um
I didn't have any when she's like what
what's your last name
I mean I'm sorry I'm not telling you I
mean like what else am I supposed to say
well there's a a number of things like
what I'd already dug the hole I was in
it so like she's staring down at me in
this hole that I've dug and she's like
hey what's your last name down there huh
she's taunting me at this point she
knows I'm not 17. and she so she's like
oh it's little Michael oh no well then
what's little Michael's last name this
is what is this that's what that's what
I'm taking issue with yeah hold on hold
up she's making a fool out of me that's
and yeah I can do that on my own okay
that's blame shifting I can do that on
my own I I take all the blame but but
she and she is not at fault here but she
added more okay but I think the here's
the thing I think the thing that I'm
trying to get to is the and if it was a
man I'd be saying the same thing Jenna
it's it doesn't have to do with gender
it definitely does not have it that's
exactly what I'm saying
this has nothing and you have failed
okay okay I'm not but what I think the
lesson I'm still humiliating this
happening again no here's here's what
it's happening again yeah here's what we
need to do as your friend here's here's
what I think we should do here y'all are
stupid y'all suck I'm okay I need some
support you are gonna find yourself in
these types of situations again right it
might be your wife gets
um my kid and his friends were watching
run over by a a spring break football
player you know that happened one time
it might be thinking it might be a guy
is that I said uh does something weird
in traffic
uh uh and then you roll down the window
or a guy who got mad at us there was a
guy who got mad at me for something I
did I was driving and he rolled down the
window and started cursing me out and my
reaction is not always nothing and you
rolled down the window and we're like
what's your problem or something like
that no I was like have you not ever
yeah whatever done something wrong in
traffic yeah so a tendency to escalate I
guess what I'm saying is that because
this is a this is a natural reaction
right you're not it's not coordinated uh
planned right
I think the thing maybe that you can do
in the future this is not who I want to
be right and you've no but listen but
it's very difficult to change something
that's instinctual but what you can do
is you can learn to recognize when you
are in a situation where your natural
tendency might be to ask like like oh
this is a person of authority in some
regard or this is some this could become
this this moment could ex this situation
can escalate and so I'm just gonna
keep first thing to do put a smile on
your face
start smiling
and that actually changes your posture
and it actually influences your mood and
it obviously influences the person's
perception of this and then while you're
smiling and they're being disarmed you
can begin to think about reasonable
responses to the situation what did you
what's that you say my name oh well
give me a moment to smile yeah and then
and now what you're doing is you can
begin to develop a new neural pathway
where it's like my name I'm not going to
true I'm not going to dig a big hole
right now oink
and I would say almost always uh maybe
you've heard of them I can think of very
few times in life when you're asked a
question like what is your name well you
shouldn't just give your actual name
yeah yeah yeah
yeah bad start yeah I think that's yeah
when you said Michael
that's the name of the card I thought
that was going to be the end of it
what's your name Michael okay Zoom nope
nope
see the thing that Chris
Jenna wants a mic so bad is there not
another mic
I'll let you let me have it hook up the
mic but before you I'm gonna take this
opportunity to continue to defend myself
uh I appreciate the advice Brett I I
don't think it's wrong
at all
um
wow oh crap what was because it's such a
natural thing for you like I'm not
saying that I don't do that because I've
like thought about it it's just my
natural response in any escalated
situation is to minimize and diffuse
yeah so I don't get myself into the
situation here's the thing but you
that's your natural instinct so you just
have to recognize when it's happening so
you can back off in the moment I
appreciate your take
I mean she's not cruel about it she's
it's gentle ribbing but Christy's like
you can't do
you can't do anything on your own you
need you need to be you need to be
watched you need to be assisted you need
to be and you know what uh I'm very
grateful
for the assistance that I have and
um
uh yeah maybe maybe I don't I don't know
if she's writing this case though
I maybe I think the it's not that I
think the world revolves around me
instead I didn't think at all
I'm just going with the flow baby I mean
it has nothing to do this is me talking
to Christy it has nothing to do with me
being some sort of Internet celebrity or
thinking that I can just I can get away
with anything because I'm something no
no no no no that's that thought honestly
was not in my head but I think Christy's
point was yeah but it's but it's in your
practice
this is the life that you live this is
like you you just stroll through it I I
mean you feel my pain on this point at
least I I yeah I don't have a uh I don't
necessarily necessarily share her
perspective on that thank you but like
not thinking about things big time like
that like I'm scared I'm on vacation but
but also like uh I was thinking about a
lot of things like I got 10 people to
dinner yes I didn't make that
reservation I had nothing to do with it
yes Christy and my assistant made the
reservation well yeah she's got a point
she's got a point but I did I was there
and I was I created a Vibe well here
what I'm getting at is so things like
that like I think you have a tendency to
not anticipate how like it making that
decision there's a real quick decision
tree right that's built that's like okay
yes I could take advantage of this kid's
ticket and then maybe we get an extra
day or something like that I could
utilize the ticket that I bought right
right but that's one step down the
decision tree yeah and then you have to
actually go out on the next two limbs
yeah then one of those notifications one
of those is this will go off without a
hitch and the other is this is going to
complicate things at some point and
create a potentially embarrassing moment
where I'm going to be found out or
called out never got there of course
obviously my brain is always like
thinking about all the things that could
go wrong that's why I get anxious about
traffic that's what NC and you see
that's what Christy does Christy is like
she's an instinctual like she she
follows the path to she she can explore
the worst case scenario as well as the
best case scenario and she's always
prepared for the worst case scenario
well it's funny because she's that's why
that's one of the great things that I
benefit from but one of the this you're
both self-preservation you have a
self-preservation thing with I also have
but your cell preservation manifests
itself in skiing in as many days as I
can in things like I gotta bring a
blanket to this event yeah like like
what you're gonna gotta be warm enough
you're gonna show up and you're gonna
have a blanket and you're gonna have
slippers you're going to be hydrated
water bottle in my pocket with the right
type of electrolytes in but here's the
thing I think you don't think about is
your self-preservation instinct does not
extend to your interactions with people
absolutely not it's like your
interaction thinking of worst case
scenarios isn't fun but but it's hard
what I'm saying is it's a downer no for
me I'm just like these things are
related ski and you know what I bet you
it'll be fine and if I can just get on
this lift then
and if I would have been like had this
whole contingency plan and like
developed a story that would have just
made me anxious and like all of that
would have been nothing I'm sitting on
the ski lift going up with my friend my
boys and like
thinking all of that anxiety all that
planning all of that effort wasn't worth
it right but okay okay I'm gonna say oh
I was wrong about all I'm going to say
something that may sound like I'm in
reinforcing something that your wife
said
and I mean that would be and I'm ripping
here but I'm saying all this in love
with the hope that you will you know not
find yourself in this situation again
so going back to the self-preservation
thing right so your self-preservation
tendency does not
uh extend to your potential interactions
with people
and so
one of the things that might be true
about what Christie is saying is I don't
care what people think about me you
don't care what people think about you
and while there's a positive side to not
caring what people think about you
there's a negative side to not caring
what people think about you because
people are the other beings that we have
to interact with and so thinking about
how someone is going to receive you
thinking about how someone is going to
interpret what you're doing or what
you're saying sometimes I think you
might be like I'm gonna hey I'm myself I
don't care what people think well yeah
but you have you have to interact with
another person who's going to receive
you in a certain way and so in this
scenario I didn't hurt Angie but no but
hold on but I'm just I'm trying I think
what maybe what Christy is saying is
that it seems like it like you're like I
don't care about anybody except me I
don't think that's true
and I don't think she's saying that as
well I think she's saying that there
might be some like pre-existing thing
because
we both have created a life where we
have a you know and this this happens
like CEO brain it's a real thing like
where yeah you have a lot of people who
figure [__] out for you on a regular
basis and you become dependent not only
do you become less good at doing things
for yourself but you become less good at
considering other people this is a very
common thing right and it's something
that we we both have to be we both have
to watch out for I don't think that I go
through like hurting people like hurting
their feelings on purpose
Angie's feelings at all like I may like
this is this might be what she was
living for I think it is
I think that she's she she loves her job
so that she can trap idiots like me
because I felt that's what she did I
don't think that what's your name
are you ready because you've been you've
been buying your tongue over there I've
been waiting patiently
um I'm open to feedback I think there is
one variable that hasn't been mentioned
yet that should be considered is
you are a grown man who has just given
Angie a child a underage boys
ski pass little Michael so she is like
okay what's your name and when you don't
know the last name that's an indication
that's the first name yeah you do not
know the last name is an indication that
you are not related to this boy you do
not know this boy yeah but I said I was
but you said but you but you clearly
weren't because you're a terrible liar
yeah that's awesome I think if I think
if you would just you think little
Michael was good good work I think I
think it was it was bad from the start
you should have just been honest and
been like oh this is my son's I've I uh
my son's friends I didn't grab mine when
we left when we left the lodge whatever
yeah that's what I said and that that
would have probably worked that wouldn't
that would have also been a lie
no that that's basically the truth okay
yeah that's the truth because yeah I
didn't do it accidentally
I said my son's friend his name is
Michael don't know his last name
uh edgy but I have it and uh yeah here
we go you did it accidentally I said
yeah here's the thing and if I would if
I would have thought ahead of time bingo
and develop some sort of plan yeah I'm
going to just say oh I've got the wrong
ticket and I turn around I didn't have I
didn't have room in my life for a
contingency plan
I don't this is okay what else Jenna
well it's just it's just an easy uh on
like it was the truth the truth is
easier to say in that situation but yeah
then you get yourself always I was just
always easier I'm not defending I'm am I
defending what any of my actions no
you're you're not right Angie's reaction
was wrong uh no I'm critiquing her
approach and and I but I know you can't
control her underage controls you can't
control how she's gonna react to it
right right right you can only control
how you're and the only thing I'm
pointing out and I'm playing I'm playing
it up a little bit I felt like I don't
actually every I'm I'm not really coming
after him I'm coming after Angie's a
little bit for the comedic effect okay
um you're so funny like I acknowledged
that I was really embarrassed because of
my because of the decisions that I made
yep right and uh it was pretty deep
it went pretty deep I was I I humiliated
myself
and
I I don't know that she trapped me but I
felt a little trapped I think that her
uh when you went back through the line
and you had your pass again and her
being in the middle of a conversation
and not looking at you was completely
intended like she definitely meant
graceful I think she knew how
embarrassing that was for you and was
allowing you to pass without giving you
a hard time about it well I'm I'm
willing to let off the hook but I'm not
willing to make her the hero of the
story I don't think she's the hero but I
think she was like dang that was a
really embarrassing situation that
happened I'm not gonna bring it up again
to that man he could just go oh look
he's got he's got his own he's got his
own past now he can go on I'm not really
comfortable you calling me a man
well that is how other people view you
what do you want to be called you are a
man and a 17 year old boy is an
understood call me little Michael from
now on
I mean child
like a little Michael in this instance
um I think maybe you're underestimating
how easy this would be to to rectify
like you don't this is a circumvent this
is not a jut yeah to prevent from
happening in the future like it's
actually doesn't take
uh it took 17 minutes at the ticket
counter
I'm just saying that
thinking like oh okay
I'm going to this event I'm going on
this trip I'm about to experience this
particular situation yes I'm going to
think about the things that I need to
have in place in order for me to have a
good time
but I also need to think about the
following things may occur in this
situation and like you're shaking your
head like you're never going to think
like that like that's not it's not that
hard though I know I know it's not hard
like the one thing that is not here for
when you decided to use a different
ticket it was like okay
today I'm doing one thing that's a
little bit Shady
what is I'm impulsive what is this Shady
thing I'm not even taking issue with the
Shady thing that you did I didn't do
anything I did well it is Shady it's
against policy
and I wouldn't have done it just because
not bad of some moral obligation just
because I'm like I don't want to deal
with the potential you think about the
future man
but I'm saying I don't think it's this
is on you because you're the future guy
I'm the president I wasn't there I know
but you've you okay I've been trained to
not have to think about the future
between you and Christy here's the thing
that ends up happening here's the thing
that happens though here's the thing
that I don't think you appreciate is the
people who love you and are in close
relationships with you they have to
think about the future for you and
that's a burden that I don't but some of
them get paid to do that I don't think I
don't get paid this is true I don't get
paid to take care of you but I'm saying
do you feel like you babysit me
and don't answer that okay yeah
and you know what I can't tell you not
to answer something that I ask you a
question I feel like such a jerk today
it's okay listen it's okay listen I'm
being listen here I just want to I just
want to take a sidebar for one second
okay you can cut this out of the edit
but don't please
I feel like I'm
portraying myself as a baby jerk
is a big baby
jerk and I'm I'm making fun of myself
okay I know I I know all these things
you're saying I also welcome the
feedback but in this context I'm also
making fun of myself is that okay
is that okay I'm not as yeah and no
one's no I just it are people going to
say that I'm a like how am I coming
across here people are gonna say
whatever they're gonna say because
listen have you seen this that's what
they say about me
don't don't don't worry about what
people say I'm of course not actually
blaming you but I'm toying with the I am
acknowledging that I want I'm glad that
you were going scuba diving
but so that we can now go together so
that I'm not the one
in total charge like I'm not I I'm not
comfortable being in charge of
my own well-being a lot of times much
less other people like I felt like I was
on top of the world I was like
facilitating 10 people having an
experience of a lifetime
including myself
um and I wasn't the only one but I was
part of that and I felt like that was
good for me like that was hey I thought
about the logistics of this
I think you succeeded I'm working that's
it sounds like a great chip it you
hadn't been it was a great trip you had
an embarrassing moment I think is is
great that we're all laughing about
because that's all we can do after the
fact is just like dang that was real
embarrassing but yes I do have a
tendency
to like when we when we go scuba diving
I'm like damn you could you could die
doing this like if I don't remember some
of the stuff that I've been trying to do
like what if something happened to
Lincoln because of me I'm like I better
bring Chase
I mean honestly I should have been
pushing harder for you to get scuba
certified for that reason that's not
that's a good tendency recognizing that
that you have some challenges in that
area is great but I'm just saying that I
think that there are some aspects of the
way that this story unfolded that the
solution is not a chaperone
that's okay that's all I'm saying I'll
I'll I I'll accept that I mean I'll
accept a week ski trip uh to chaperone
I won't say no to that so yeah and so a
little enablement goes a long way yeah
Chrissy and I can hang out it'll be fun
and the thing I have opinions about and
the thing that you're not going to be
able to avoid
do you think that you're not going to be
able to avoid is finding yourself in
these situations because even if you say
like you know good heart I'm not gonna
do I gotta go to get her I'm not yeah
that's what I'm getting at that's the
point I'm it's like having great
intentions I think is what matters most
all right well yeah but how does
somebody receive your actions is
actually a thing is a part of being a
human and so I'm saying that I don't
think I would be exploring the story at
all and being like making fun of myself
and exploring all of this in every way
that we are you're not a bad person if I
had hurt somebody I think you're missing
my point
no yeah I'm saying that yeah I'm saying
that the thing
sometimes you don't think about how this
thing will unfold I'm not talking about
Angie's feelings I'm talking about the a
situation with a person it's like oh I'm
making a decision right now that might
lead to an inner an uncomfortable
interaction an interaction in which
someone might be offended or have their
feelings hurt me
exactly and what happens is well I think
you get into those situations and like
the reason you escalate it is because
you go into self-preservation mode in
the midst of the interaction and what
that person's thinking and what that
person's feeling is not on your radar
and I'm saying that I actually so it's
not that you didn't care about Angie
it's that you're like okay this you
don't say oh this girl is trying to do
her job and I just need to be honest
with her and admit my fault you
immediately why you want to see my phone
you're doing it without even thinking
about it is what I'm saying I think the
most interesting thing is asking the
question of like what why is that your
reaction like why is that the reaction
that you have in the midst of that
because if you would figure out what
that is it doesn't happen all the time
well I think it happens more than than
you perceive that it happens I see I see
it happening with other people and I'm
like he didn't see how that came off but
it's fine it's fine he's he's doesn't
mean he he means well it's not like
you're like I'm gonna go out and I'm
gonna intentionally do things but
because this is again what your greatest
strength is can be your greatest
weakness so not caring about what people
think is one of the things that makes
you you makes you entertaining makes you
fun makes people interested in the
things that you're going to say and do
your unpredictability all that stuff is
a positive but when you have that
strength you have to consider how that
strength can become a weakness in
certain situations and that doesn't mean
that you're trying to oh I'm going to be
less of myself it just means oh me being
myself sometimes might get me into a
situation where I end up having to say
something that is hurtful or uncalled
for and so I just need to be cognizant
of that I have my own [__] that I deal
with it's a different thing I might be
too much on the people-pleasing side and
so sometimes there are times when I need
to stand up for myself or I need to say
something we all have our own [__] I'm
just saying it's a strength but you need
to think about what the negative thing
the negative aspect of it is and I think
if you do you'll find oh I'm in one of
those situations right now I recognize
that and now I can actually think about
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna how I'm
gonna proceed do you think okay all
right before I ask something else
okay I'm gonna take a little breath here
thank you for the feedback
do you think that the conversation that
I had
was it last night that we went to that
movie
no night before last
do you think
I'm just trying to think of another
example like when I was talking to the
guy beside like it was you then me and
then the guy on the left who was on his
phone that I started talking to
do you think that there was something
inappropriate about that conversation
that was an interesting guy I was trying
to think was he was he really cold to me
because of how I was coming off to him
or was that on him or was that on me
because I observed that like he was
he had the strangest driest sense of
humor or he was the meanest person I've
ever struck up a conversation with and
was that my fault yes
because I actually wanted to talk to you
about this so here we get to talk about
it on the podcast really because I'm
thinking about it too I'm like I'm
having here's this guy we're sitting at
a movie premiere me you and this guy
he's not with anybody else there's an
empty seat beside him I'm gonna be
friendly
are you right but your idea of friendly
is coming out of the gate with some
aggression sometimes now here's the
thing
you don't what was the aggression
well I don't like aggressively friendly
no no you're I wasn't me I was I was
being friendly well but it wasn't I I I
will acknowledge you but come on strong
but I wouldn't call it aggression it's
not aggression busting his balls a
little bit and then because and then
when you begin to think that he was
busting your balls oh he bust my boss
first you're nah you're busting his
balls again yeah this is not always a
bad thing but yeah well let's here's a
here this is the thing I wanted to talk
to you about is not that I'm that
concerned about you potentially digging
a hole with somebody and having to dig
yourself out of it and then maybe oh by
the end of the night your best friends
maybe that can happen right I wasn't
impersonating anybody I can't remember
how I started I'm with you
like you're with another person right
and I'm that this wasn't that big of a
deal because we're sitting there and
you're talking to the guy but I think
it's emblematic of the type of
interaction that can happen in public
which is like and I think about this a
lot I'm like okay I'm going into this
situation Rhett and Link are going
together into this social situation
we're going to meet somebody and we met
that other we met that couple right when
we walked in yeah and I'm like I know
how this is gonna go
the Link's going to take charge of the
conversation he's going to say some
spicy things he's going to talk about
something
and I'm and like if he says something
that is potentially offensive that he
doesn't mean to I have to be there to
like monitor the situation and play play
like referee and I don't think you have
any perception that that is something
that happens if you talk to your wife
about this she'll say yes this is what I
do when we go into situations
and so again you're a fun guy there's no
questioning that like oh Link's fun he's
going to take the initiative bring this
up he's going to take the initiative and
he's and with that situation I'm like
though as you were having that
conversation with that guy
he would because you kept talking to him
and you were you like you know do you
remember how it started
uh I don't remember the first question I
know he was on his phone should I talk
to him because he's on his phone and I
was he was alone but you but I heard the
first couple things you said to him and
I was like how's this going to go
I don't remember what it was was it like
because it was that movie air so I was
like talking about I was talking to you
about do we need to be sneaker heads if
we're here because that guy thought we
were sneaker heads because he said I
didn't know you guys were sneaker heads
and then I'm like
are you oh I asked him about his shoes
because then I turned to him and I was
like
um
are you wearing Nikes because this is a
Nike movie I think that's what I started
the conversation but that's not how you
say things
you know what I'm saying you come a
little bit I don't think you perceive it
sometimes but you might be like
oh
Nike so you're trying to fit in too like
you'll you you'll say something that
again
some people I would say the majority of
people are going to respond like oh
who's this guy like I'm going to respond
positively to this guy's kind of vibe
but what I'm saying is this and his
response was
I'm just wearing I'm just wearing shoes
it doesn't matter what you wear you wear
anything don't worry don't worry about
what other people think just wear what
you want to wear
and so he was he came in strong with a
response like oh I'm not I like this guy
I'm not saying that particular
interaction I'm just saying that as your
best friend who is with you at a lot of
these things when we start walking up to
somebody the predominant thing on my
mind is
well that's not fair to you and I'm
sorry and so I'm just saying that
sometimes you don't like you you don't I
don't think you have a consideration for
like oh I'm gonna come in here and I'm
gonna say whatever the hell I want to
because I'm myself and I'm Gonna Be
Myself wherever I go and like that's a
good thing but like but I know you're
with other you're with somebody else I
guess I well I appreciate you saying
that how this impacts you because my my
thing is like
my motive is to just spark up a
conversation with somebody just to just
to have a good time and not and not at
their expense I understand that but I
think you do that and you know that I
think sometimes you behave as if you're
the only one there
that's what I'm saying like oh real no
I'm just saying and again I think it has
you know you're an only child there's
other there's things like damn no I'm
I'm being real here it's like you know I
grew up with a brother it's just like
you can't like like you you walk into a
situation you're like oh the other guy's
here I have to kind of like accommodate
the fact that he's here and so sometimes
you'll be in a social situation and it's
just like you're coming in hot
and it's just like all right I'm gonna
throw some [__] out there and see where
the cards fall and you guys can pick
them up and do what you want by the way
I think that's why
i s if we go to something I split up
because I don't I don't feel like yeah I
mean it's like you know I don't want to
you know you talk to who you want to
talk to in the way that you want to talk
to people and like that I don't I'm much
more concerned about you than the guy I
was talking to in this instance like I
last thing I want is for you to feel
like you got to be myself but no but I
think the thing is is like I appreciate
that and I do find myself at certain
social situations where we split up
which is fine with me where I'll walk
back up and I'll walk into a
conversation where it's like oh [__]
link is doing his thing right now well
it got really I mean about the Little
Dicky story from where there's a number
of stories you know there's a number of
stories where I'll kind of walk in and
again
there's a good part to this we've talked
about it before you take initiative in a
social situation you'll go talk to
anybody like these are good qualities
but they're qualities that have to be
metered and and also considered as they
as they happen in social situations
because
I don't think the the answer should be
like well okay rep feels like he's got
to be like there to like make sure
things don't go off the rails with me so
therefore I'm going to always split up I
don't think that's the application to me
the application would be like that
wouldn't be fine I can enter into a
social situation and actually before I
say the thing that I'm thinking like it
I sometimes I feel like there's a
tendency to be like if I say or feel it
I there's a compulsion I have to I have
to say or do it right now
because if I don't I'm repressing myself
or something I'm just saying it's like
as an outsider looking in I'm not saying
that's what's going on that's how it
seems I don't and so so as I'm
experiencing it I'm like oh man it's
like
and then I think everyone else
so it's almost like you come into a
conversation and you are the catalyst
So you you're like here's what I'm gonna
do I'm going to come into this social
situation and I've got a magic trick and
so the first thing that's going to
happen is my magic trick and then
everyone else has to respond to my magic
trick
do you see what I'm saying like that's
the dynamic that you're unintentionally
creating
and so as somebody who's like right
there with you is your best friend
coming into the situation I'm like all
right here we go
but it's but I don't I I don't think of
it as a magic trick I think of it as
banter cutting it up I do think of it as
a playground I get it and it this is
next to a guy I need to talk to this guy
what's a fun way to talk to this guy I'm
thinking about how I decided I told him
I said
I was thinking about what shoes I was
going to wear to this thing and I I
decided that I should wear Nikes I
wasn't I wasn't badgering him about his
shoes
that I was I was sharing about I don't
remember the specifics of the
conversation no I do and that was it so
it was about it was about my shoes and
that's when his response was well I
don't think you should care at all but
they think about your shoes wear
whatever shoes you want to wear and then
you were like yeah this isn't
sponsored by Nike
this is not a Nike movie
yeah I'm just saying that it kind of was
but it not in I'm just saying that my
sense based on my my intuition and
experience with you is just like
I'm not gonna have to step in and make
sure that link doesn't piss this guy off
but that that rarely happens that never
happens
people think I'm might think I'm strange
but they're not they're I don't think
their feelings are going to be hurt or
they're going to get angry like I've
never gotten close to like getting in a
fight with somebody
except for going back to the ski ticket
to Angie like I don't we're not we're
now talking about something different
that has nothing to do with aggression
but and you use the word you say that I
aggressively try to connect I've only
put myself out there and listen but I
don't I'm not aggressive towards am I
I'm only telling you how I feel about it
because you asked me yeah do you feel
like the the city and I was like well
actually yeah I wanted to talk to you I
didn't I wasn't going to be like hey the
way you interacted with that guy
I the thing I was going to say is like
hey next time we get ready to go into
something like I can we have a
conversation about how I feel when we go
into when we go into a social situation
okay and did we just have it do you what
do you hear me saying I want to make
sure that you understand because I'm
again I'm not saying that you should be
a different person I'm just saying that
who you are is something that you have
to consider me when you come on so
strong it puts you in a position that
you need you have to respond to and if
you want to go to parties by yourself
and do whatever you want to and see
where the cards fall but I'm saying that
like when you go with go somewhere with
me or with your wife or with a friend
like just so you know it is the thing
they're preoccupied with
is a sense of like
okay is he going to do something that
kind of makes things a little bit
awkward for what it feels like for his
own entertainment
and maybe it is it is like hey I'm going
to I want to connect with somebody it's
like well but it is for my own
entertainment but hey I'm also there yes
I've got interesting things to say as
well and people might be like well you
can just say why do you have to tell
link what he needs to say it's like yeah
someone sometimes when somebody creates
naturalizing such a strong Dynamic and
because I'm like that's not my
personality I kind of like I got tall
guy syndrome right we like we're already
really big so we make ourselves small a
lot of times and we and we don't come on
very strong we come on kind of soft and
then we get to know you but when you've
got somebody there who is coming on very
very strong and he's in you're gonna
always be there at these things it's
just like it you set the dynamic in a
way that then everyone else has to
respond to everybody's okay like all
right this guy's weird he's saying weird
things he's talking about my shoes he's
whatever it might be and now everybody's
responding to it and so if you that all
the time it can become kind of an
exhausting thing for people who are with
you all the time that's what I'm saying
in those social situations I'm not
saying that like it happens like on a
daily basis yeah yeah it this is very
much a social thing this is the this is
the party thing
and this is different than the other
thing
I I tend to think that there is a there
is a root that and I'm not listen I'm
not a therapist because I'm not going to
give any advice
I'm just my guess is that there is a
rooted thing
that causes you to find yourself in the
in those kind of both of those social
situations I think it actually is a
common route
that would be like I'm gonna say this
thing in this situation like I'm not
taking my phone out
is the same is there's a common route to
like I'm going to come into this group
and just say something that makes people
feel uncomfortable because it's kind of
fun and you know what a lot of times
it's actually going to lead to a
stronger connection with somebody
I just don't understand why I mean in my
mind though talking about the Neurosis
of me picking out the type of the brand
of shoe I'm gonna wear to this movie
was something that I thought this guy
would get a kick out of and he might
enjoy meeting me yeah but all I'm saying
is that there's a there's sort of a
there's a ribbing yeah and something
there's a tall there's a tone of like
there's a type of person you gotta
there's a type of person that gives
people nicknames
you know what I'm saying there's a type
of person that gives people nicknames me
you are that type of person is that a
bad thing in and of itself it is not a
bad thing but one of the things I
wouldn't want to demean someone right
here but here's the thing
I think it's not again you have a good
you have a great heart you're not a bad
guy you're not an [__]
but just just get something to be
considered people who give people
nicknames one of the ways that that can
be interpreted is as they are orienting
all the people in their lives according
to the way that they see them
this guy is tall stilt
still I call you you know I don't give
that many people's nickname no but I'm
just but I only give employees nicknames
no they're and it's not bad but it's I'm
just I'm not I'm just gonna can you help
me out here I'm not saying anything that
makes any sense we're at time if you
don't want to say it no please do please
because I listen I don't want this to be
one of those things where
I'm I'm used to people talking [__]
about me but like I don't want this to
be like the competition episode where
I'm trying to get linked to see
something negative about himself I'm
saying all these things out of love and
I asked me the question I think Jenna I
want I want you to have the floor and
I'm not going to interrupt you
I would may I just respond to this oh
yes
I agree
that this is helpful feedback that I
ask for
this is helpful feedback I ask for it I
think and I'm fine with it being in this
venue because I'm I'm fine with that
I don't want I think it's good
entertainment too
but this is a conversation that we could
have on our own and it would be
different because it's not there's not
an entertainment value but it is it is
it is I welcome it and it's valuable
and I don't think you should be
criticized for it
now if that happens
yeah this is not about taking my side or
his side I'm we're on the same side yes
we're on the same side don't pick a side
there's only one side I ask for this and
I find it very fascinating and I would
love to listen to a podcast of other
people talking about it that's why I'm
totally game to do it because I think
it's good content and it's honest
but we are on the same side and I
appreciate what you've said and I want
to hear what Jenna has to say
I agree you were both on the same side
and the side is the side of growth and I
also feel that I just have a a different
relationship
to you than what red has so I don't I
don't feel like I have
um any comment either way on the
discussion honestly but like from my
perspective as your employee none of it
bothers me uh and the work that I have
to do
so that's
I feel like my takeaway I think that's
helpful it is helpful because I think
what you said about because red was
saying
this is a dynamic that he and he's sure
that Christy also experiences and then
other you know there's there I think
there's other friends at times that
experience it you know
um but the reason I think with Jenna
right is because once people have the
opportunity to get to know you your
employees know you they're like oh the
first time I met him he said something
really awkward to me that kind of
offended me but it turns out that's just
link and now I know that he's a good guy
and he didn't mean that so again I I
think that that's the dynamic and so I'm
often with you where we're entering into
the first interaction with somebody or
some very like tertiary like you're
trying to surface level process me and
I'm like and you have I would have taken
that I would be having more fun if I
didn't enter into this conversation with
somebody with a level of like
tension and like some people might say
why do you give a [__] man just don't
even care just like happy-go-lucky and
it's just like well it's harder to do
that it's harder to do that when you're
half of a Duo that's kind of oh we're
there as the as these two guys yeah it's
like and I would and I wouldn't want you
to do that
yeah it's like it's hard to it's hard to
accommodate it must be accommodated you
know what I'm saying I don't think when
you go someplace with me you think how
am I going to accommodate Rhett in this
situation no it's not you're not
thinking about that but most people who
are with you are going into the
situation thinking how do I accommodate
link because I know that's going to be a
part of this interaction I like to be
handled
I think is is another through line here
that I'm realizing something about me I
like to be handled I like to get a
massage I like to go I like to have a
social net where it's like I can I can
just have some fun and then we'll pick
up the pieces later or I can trust
someone else to pick up the pieces
immediately or like patch it up or I can
dive in this ocean knowing that like
oh God this is not my life is not
completely in my own hands like I love
that feeling I love this I love a feel
the feeling of just being just letting
go you like and in social situations
where to me it's about fun and it's a
playground like I I'm drawn to
situations where I can just
let go and see what happens like it's
it's there's a Vitality to my experience
but as I'm saying it I hear your
feedback which is
well that's
that's only looking through your own
lens and that would be very simple what
if every single person of the party had
the same mentality right it would be
your [__] chaos right and so and I
would love it by the way I think I think
I don't think I would hate it I don't
think he would it's not that I want to
be the center of attention I don't think
that's a center you want to live a life
with no filter and I think well I wanna
abandoned it's there's more like there's
this freedom I think there's so much of
my life that's like I think so hard
about it that if I can get out of my
head and just get into like living then
it feels so good because and that's good
I'm just explaining myself I'm not
defending myself
and so I it helps me to understand that
there's other things to take into
account like I have this desire
in a party setting where there's no
stake I I feel like there's no stakes
and it's all just about fun and whether
it's the critic in my own head or
whatever it is it's like there's a lot
of
crunching down so like the places where
I can let loose I find myself wanting to
let loose in a big way because it feels
so good
uh and I think that
you know I take the feedback that that
has an impact on the people closest to
me and that has an impact on strangers
too it hasn't it has more impacts than
I'm willing to consider and it's like
it's a bummer you know because and it's
because you're right and it's like and
it's like okay so now it's like well how
can I does that mean I have to have a
little less fun
I don't think I don't think so and I
know but it feels that way but but see
the message is not blink
you need to be reeled in
you're too much fun or or whatever I'm
not yeah I think I am hearing that I
need to be real then it's not it's not
because it's it it impacts other people
I think I'm not the only person I think
I'm not the center of the world I think
the message is uh I do think that the
filter thing is a good analogy because I
do think that you like to live life
without a filter and again as we've
established and as I'm as everyone
listening would agree that is one of the
things that we love about you
is that you're gonna say the first thing
that comes to your mind
however because you're a good guy you
have a good heart and you love people I
would say that there are instances where
a
a filter is an act of love
does that make sense so the actually
having the filter in certain situations
can be an act of love because it means
that I'm taking into account how my
actions impact
the people I'm with the group dynamic
and so
I don't think that it because I think
that that
motivation appeals to you you actually
do care you actually
people who don't care what people what
anybody thinks about them
truly are [__]
because what people think about you is
actually important because I want people
to be happy you but that's actually not
who you are you do actually care about
people and when people and I care what
people think about me yeah right you
care about people's experience but I
just don't think that you've considered
because of people you know it's like
this isn't the kind of thing I want to
talk to you about it's not the kind of
thing I want to be like hey before we
have talked before we go into this party
can we have a little pow-wow yeah so
that we don't get ourselves into the one
of these situations or can I just tell
you how I feel in these situations like
I don't want to have that conversation I
don't want to be a buzz skill that's the
last thing that I want to do I'm just
saying saying that I think that
ultimately
having those Tendencies is all good
but it's just like hey when Superman
goes into the he starts giving you a
massage he has to think to himself oh if
I give the full massage that Superman
wants to get I will I will kill this
person does that make sense so like you
have to have an appreciation for your
strengths so you can actually utilize
them in a way that's beneficial to
people and ultimately to you I think
ultimately this will be
beneficial to you it's not just about
how you can accommodate other people but
I think that all I think there is a
there is a better reality ultimately for
you that isn't just hey I'm going in
there and stirring the [__] up and
seeing where the cards fall and that's
what I do in social situations
I think that there's a fuller experience
which is like yeah I'm doing that but
I'm also like metering that and
funneling that and being a little bit
more strategic with that strength that I
have so it can be used to benefit people
not just myself
yeah I just have to figure out how to
like
I just want to jump out of the plane you
know
and I think you know the funny thing is
is I actually think that this is a
tendency that you have been and I'm
telling you that's a skydiving analogy
by the way this is a tendency that
you've been has been increasing
year over year one of the biggest
differences between you now and you from
10 years ago is that like that I never
thought about that in a million years
there was never a moment where I was
like we're going to the situation who
knows what Link's gonna do what am I
going to have to do to figure this out
and so I think that there has been some
there has been growth in a good way and
you like I'm embracing who I am I'm
being myself
but sometimes as an outsider looking in
it feels like there's such a
commitment to expressing yourself
without a filter
first thing you think you say it first
thing you feel you say it you do it
that becomes a thing that everyone has
to adjust I hear that you know and so
the the adjustment over time has
increased
so that now I go into social situations
with a sense of trepidation which 10
years ago it never would have never been
on my mind
and I'm not saying you should go back to
who you were I'm saying that there's
growth it's just the growth has to be
managed in
um you know
managed
yeah I'm not jumping out of the plane
alone I'm I'm
um it's a tandem jump yeah
or or there's a group a group it's a
group of people there's nine and when
there's there's Lincoln in his three
friends and then there's one if there's
one guy who's like this is what I do and
I jump out of a plane I go as fast as I
possibly can and they're like yeah but
we talked about how we were all gonna
like we're adult there's a plan we're
all gonna do this together
and I don't want to choke you while
we're doing it yeah and it's just like
well hey I don't want to every once in a
while I gotta jump out of a plane and go
as fast as I possibly can it's like okay
that's great but when we say that we're
going to jump out of the plane as a
group let's be thinking about the group
not just your own jump
I think that's why when I went to
Rolling loud and I got separated from
Lincoln that I had so much fun
yeah
because and so maybe you need to give
yourself those experiences but I think
that you don't need to give yourself
experiences
goes to the movie theater alone or goes
out to eat alone and has weird
interactions with the waiter I don't
like movies yeah but it's it's that's
the thing is that it's the people the
interaction with people that is that's
my skydiving I think a lot it's that
social thing it's like
I'm you know and when people that love
you they can appreciate it and it can be
fun sometimes it can be like okay let's
pull it let's pull it in we've done
we've had a lot of moments but I like
the strangers I like getting I like
interacting with strangers
that's evident
so that that was the thing about the
concert was I was interacting with
nothing but strangers I was in a sea of
strangers and anywhere I could turn I
could interact with somebody and it was
fun
um so
maybe I'll just maybe I'll just start
going to
conventions but maybe I'll start
crashing weddings and making them all
about me
yeah okay I you know this is this this
is this is good this is good I mean this
weekend we're going out me and you
so
we're gonna have to
I'll think about this leading up to that
because we're gonna have a good time I
appreciate you I want me and you to be
able to do stuff and have a good time I
don't want to be now I want to cry
at the end of this hey let's just make
come full circle cry a little bit I
don't feel
embarrassed now like I did on the ski
slip
I'm just manipulating You by crying to
feel sorry for me no that's not true
um you know it's just emotional to feel
like okay
what is this inside of me that wants to
come out and like it goes out sideways
in it it's funny sometimes but then at
other times it's like man it's like you
don't want to I don't wanna you know I
don't want to be the guy that's giving
people uh uh that are closest to me like
a shitty a shitty time because because
I'm having the best time in my life it's
like that's that sucks
yeah and I don't wanna and I don't want
I don't want I'm sorry for getting
emotional that's gonna complicate things
I don't want you uh
to feel like again and I'm sure I I do
care about what people think a lot too
much and so I try to meter on everything
I say but
I don't want people to think that the
the takeaway is that well just like told
link to be less link and that's that's
that's this thing I because I think I
agree with what you're saying you know
at every turn I I agree I it's feedback
that I've gotten and it's not just from
you it's it's you know it's like people
who love me the most have given me this
feedback so like I feel that I feel that
well I appreciate you you listening to
it and taking it to heart
so I I would like to apologize
to Angie
because we need to wrap this up Angie
think about that think about somebody
listen let's just go ahead if you work
at UH
so what was it uh is the Park City the
Cannons Resort
uh and you are the guy who had an
interaction or you know somebody who
knows link who and you're the guy that
came up make sure that Angie and
whatever her actual name is watches this
whole episode because it'll be such a
[__] mind trip
that it ends with link cry
[Applause]
validate everything she was already
thinking about you based on the
interaction she's like yeah this is
exactly what I expected watching this
guy's podcast I I feel like this whole
conversation is just a perfect cap
encapsulation of like links chaotic
storytelling energy it's just like we
went on there's a whole dang Journey
it's entertaining it's great man we
wouldn't be here without it just so it's
just you know
it's always there it ain't never until
Somebody's Crying yeah
yeah and I'd I prefer for it to be me so
okay I got no wreck I got no
recommendation I'm exhausted hashtag ear
biscuits uh let us know what you think I
bet you got some stuff that you're
thinking
please leave us a voicemail and let us
know 1-888 earpod one
wow
hi this is Ava I just thought you guys
really should know if you look up Sims 3
University expansion pack the opposite
household
um there's a Wikipedia page entry for it
um there's no confirmed evidence of this
but I've been convinced for years that
household is based off of YouTube just
to look at the images of the characters
and see their different personality
traits that I I find you will agree
I thought that was something you guys
should know
thank you Linda have a great day
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign